-Його можна навіть вдягти, виглядає зовсім непогано.
Зіпсованим він не є.
- Він навіть зовсім новий!
- Так, виглядає наче новий!
- Він і є новий! Ніхто ще не ходив у ньому!
Може, пошукаємо другий?
(сміх)
Вечір посеред робочого тижня. 35-градусна спека.
Західнонімецьке місто Бонн.
Чого лише не знайти на березі Рейну, якщо придивитися.
Вражені декілька десятків молодих людей, що прийшли на набережну збирати сміття.
- Це просто жахливо, що люди просто розкидають своє сміття.
Воно опиняється в морях, в річках і руйнує цілі екосистеми,
впливає на багатьох тварин.
Акцію зі збору сміття вже втретє організувала викладачка йоги Анналєна ван Бік.
Дівчина ніколи не знає, скільки осіб відгукнеться на її пост у Фейсбук цього разу,
і радіє кожному учаснику.
- Він знайде все їстівне.
Рукавички та пакети надало міське комунальне підприємство БоннОранж,
що відповідає за вивіз сміття в місті.
Про мотивацію подбала Анналєна.
В обмін на заповнені сміттям пакети дівчина проведе безкоштовно годину йоги у парку.
- Багато хто залюбки займається йогою. І я подумала: я поєднаю це.
Поєднання спорту та збору сміття стало справжнім трендом у Європі.
Широкої популярності набув так званий плоггінг -
збір сміття під час пробіжки.
Масштаби побутового забруднення довкілля вражають дедалі більше німців.
Близько 220 кг лише пластикової упаковки
викидає кожен німець щороку у смітник.
А іноді і повз смітник. І це найгірший показник у Євросоюзі.
За розрахунками Всесвітнього фонду дикої природи,
якщо ситуацію не змінити, до 2050 року в океані буде більше пластику, ніж риби,
а також він буде в шлунку кожного морського птаха.
Не дивно. 45 хвилин роботи на невеличкому клаптику набережної - 12 повних мішків сміття.
Час на заслужений відпочинок.
Анналєна розуміє, що йогою та акціями зі збору сміття
екологічну катастрофу, в якій перебуває світ через пластик, не відвернеш.
Тому сама дівчина ухвалила свідоме рішення -
взагалі не створювати сміття.
- Косметику чи миючі засоби можна самому зробити.
Наприклад, рідкий засіб для прання, шампунь чи зубну пасту.
Це можна зробити дуже просто вдома і лише з трьох інгредієнтів.
Утім, якщо зовсім відмовитися від пластику важко,
то зменшити його використання дуже просто:
можна купувати фрукти та овочі без упаковки чи пакетів,
користатися послугами магазинів чи ринків,
де можна насипати у власну тару сипучі продукти.
Та, звісно, організовувати акції зі збору сміття чи брати в них участь.